in this video I have the proof of the
second case for the distributive law in
this case we're showing that a
intersection B Union a intersection C is
a subset of a intersection B Union C so
let's start by saying that suppose that
X is an element of a intersection B
Union a intersection C then we know that
X is an element of a intersection B or X
is an element of a intersection C and we
know this because of the definition of
the Union from here we can then state
that X is an element of a and X is an
element of B or X is an element of a and
X is an element of C from that we can
deduce that X is an element of a and X
is an element of B or X is an element of
C and here we we sort of factored out
the X as an element of a and and then
regrouped X is an element of B or X is
an element of C and from here we can by
definition write X is M a and X is an
element of B Union C which finally we
can state X's and elements of a
intersection B Union C which is what we
want to show so there you have it we've
proved that X is an element of both of
these and therefore this is a subset of
dis and we've shown that both sides of
the equation are subsets of each other
and therefore the distributive law is in
fact true it's proven